[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute einen 40
kuchen das ist ein sehr sehr lecker und
erfrischender kuchen und ihr könnt
später wenn ihr mögt das ganze als
solches präsentieren schön klassisch
oder ihr macht es wie ich und verwandelt
die physische in bienen ich zeige euch
gleich wie das funktioniert wir machen
jetzt hier aber zuallererst mal den
rührteig dafür nehme ich mir die
küchenmaschine das ganze funktioniert
auch mit dem handrührgerät dann braucht
ihr halt nur so ein zwei minuten länger
es gebe ich die eier als erstes rein und
auch schon zucker und gerne auch eine
gute prise salz die hebt nämlich noch
meine süßen geschmack und dann werden
die eier mit dem zucker so ungefähr vier
minuten lang richtig schön bequem ist
geschlagen
[Musik]
nach den vier minuten geben wir dann
sonnenblumenöl und maracuja nektar dazu
ich finde das für sich und maracuja
generell einfach super gut zusammen
passt ihr könnt jetzt auch anderen saft
nehmen wenn ihr mögt sind als nächstes
kommen die trockenen zutaten dazu dafür
einfach mehl und backpulver vorab
miteinander vermischen und hin zu sieben
das ganze nur ganz kurz unterrühren und
dann ist der teig fertig
[Musik]
so jetzt sind tag einmal einfüllen ich
habe hier meinen back rahmen den habe
ich eingestellt auf 25 x 25 cm
untendrunter backpapier und jetzt den
teig einfüllen ein bisschen
glattstreichen und ich verrate ich auch
schon mal die backzeit es gibt nämlich
sehr sehr schnell
180 grad ober und unterhitze wichtig
immer vorhalten
und dann braucht der boden echt nur
zwölf minuten dann ist ja schon durch
und dann vollständig auskühlen lassen
[Musik]
so der boden ist jetzt komplett
abgekühlt ich lass dir mal gerne im bug
raum abkühlen entferne jetzt in bagdad
mit dem bug formloser damit ich mir da
auch nichts kaputt reise und dann drehe
ich ihnen einmal um
[Musik]
jetzt sitze ich den bug rahmen wieder
darum herum ich mache jetzt auch nicht
sauber das spare ich mir jetzt
[Musik]
auf den boden streiche ich jetzt
aprikosen fruchtaufstrich der passt
geschmacklich perfekt und wenn ich einen
kurzen der mikrowelle erwärmt er bitte
schön flüssig und kann richtig schön in
den teig eindringen deswegen habe ich
den jetzt auch umgedreht damit die
offenen poren oben sind und das ganze im
richtig schön geschmack annehmen kann
jetzt habe ich den boden kurz zur seite
gegeben jetzt jetzt weiter mit unserer
leckeren creme dafür habe ich hier
schlagsahne ganz kalt aus dem
kühlschrank und die werde ich jetzt hier
zusammen mit etwas sahne fest in der
küchenmaschine aufschlagen falls ihr
keine küchenmaschine gehabt wie gesagt
das geht auch alles mit dem
handrührgerät also gar kein thema
[Musik]
so die sonne sitzt steife machen auch
direkt weiter ich habe eine weitere
schüsse in der ich jetzt schmandt gebel
stand könnt ihr auch creme fraiche
nehmen falls ihr beides nicht da habt
dann könnt ihr auch die gleiche menge
mascarpone nehmen das funktioniert auch
wunderbar und das führe ich jetzt ganz
kurz nur mit puderzucker seine fest und
vanille extrakt
[Musik]
ganz ganz wichtig verrührt den schmand
wirklich nur zehn sekunden nicht mehr
sonst wird er sehr flüssig und danach
einfach die sahne in zwei drei schritten
unterheben das macht ihr am besten mit
einem teig schaber und mit ganz viel
liebe und jetzt kommt diese flüssige
creme auf den boden und wie schön glatt
verstrichen
[Musik]
unser kuchen kommt jetzt für eine halbe
stunde in den kühlschrank ich nutzt aber
die gelegenheit und machte ihr süße
kleine bienchen wie gesagt er könnte den
kuchen auch ohne deco servieren dann
kommt gleich nur noch der quasi der
frucht spiegel oben drauf aber ich
wollte das jetzt so gestalten damit ihr
auch eine möglichkeit habt entweder für
den kindergeburtstag oder einfach mal so
ich mache ich finde es als erwachsener
total sie so ich zeige euch jetzt was
ich hier habt und zwar braucht ihr
kirche das sind die hier die sind
nämlich schön groß und den saft dürft
ihr nicht wechselten den brauchen wir
nämlich gleich noch so die habe ich gut
abgetrocknet dass es sehr sehr wichtig
die müssen schön trocken sein
und dann habe ich mir ein bisschen zeit
peter kuvertüre geschmolzen und in einen
spritzbeutel mit einer lok hülle getan
jetzt hat ja die biene quasi streifen
das könnte jetzt hier ganz gut nachahmen
dann mache ich da gleich einfach noch
ein mund und zwei augen dazu und das
hier sind ganz einfach zucker augen die
findet ihr bei kaufland in der buck
abteilung zuckersüß genau
[Musik]
und für die flügel nehmen wir jetzt ganz
einfach gehobelte mandeln und stecken
die rein das geht auch ganz einfach weil
die so weich sind ja auch komma des
abgebrochen da muss ich kurz abändern
bewirkt sodass gegeben so perfekt die
bienchen sind jetzt fertig und ich finde
ich richtig richtig knuffig habe schon
meine lieblings bieber die besonders aus
naja ich werde jetzt ein guss
vorbereiten dafür habe ich ja hier wie
gesagt noch den saft aus der dose den
gebe ich schon mal in meinen kopf hat
ist noch aus noch nicht einschalten den
füllen wir jetzt auf mit maracuja nektar
dann gibt es nämlich auch noch eine
schöne farbe und natürlich geschmack da
gehe ich dann speisestärke dazu schön
klümpchen frei verrühren und dann erst
den herd einschalten und unter ständigem
rühren eindecken lassen
[Musik]
sobald der bus eingedeckt ist kurz vor
fünf minuten stehen lassen damit er ganz
leicht ausdampfen kann und dann einfach
auf die gekühlte torte geben
ich gebe direkt im anschluss die bienen
um drauf ich mag dass er und ordentlich
ihr könnt das auch ganz akkurat drei
anrei machen ganze ihr möchtet und
sobald der gus oben fest wird das dauert
so ungefähr 15 minuten ist die torte
direkte wir bereit und ihr könnt sie
sofort verspeist rate euch nun im bug
vom löser damit ihr euch da auch nichts
kaputt macht und löst so den bug rahmen
und ihr könnt die torte auch vorbereiten
am vortag
und dann ganz einfach im kühlschrank
lagern und generell hält sie sich drei
tage lang denkt nur daran dass sie kühlt
und ich glaube auch solange tiefer und
sowieso nicht weil sie sehr sehr frisch
und leicht schmeckt und da geht auf
jeden fall auch immer noch ein zweites
oder drittes stückchen ihr könnt die
ganz genauen mengenangaben hier unten in
der video beschreibung nachlesen
ihr könnt euch ein screenshot machen
abzug auf land und dort die ganzen
zutaten einkaufen und das ganze dann
nachmachen ich freue mich übrigens immer
über eure wunderschönen fotos mit dem
hashtag igs kitchen auf instagram und
dann hoffe ich dass für uns auch beim
nächsten mal sehen denkt an den kanal zu
abonnieren wenn es noch nicht gemacht
habt und ich sage bist du nächste mal
auf die kitchen schildes
[Musik]